bien tu as a way pour aller mettre sur
la panne de tongzhou je sais ça va la
main toute droite on va pouvoir réparer
les autres mais qu'arrive-t-il à l'ila
le doudou de noémie à mono et b il a
fait du vélo et il est tombé
et alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé il
s'est cassé la patte
si lille a s'est cassé la patte il faut
donc aller à l'hôpital pour la soigner
l'hôpital ses murs blancs ces piqûres et
ses grandes blues
un lieu qui peut effrayer les enfants et
c'est pour contrer ce sentiment qu'un
dispensaire provisoire s'est installé à
versailles il ya des enfants quand on
leur demande si ça fait un peu ce que
c'est d'aller chez le médecin à
l'hôpital et tout ça il rattache
beaucoup à des maladies très graves
l'hôpital c'est la mort ou des choses
comme ça et là on leur montre que
finalement non à l'hôpital il ya plein
de gens qui sont soignés que toutes les
maladies ne sont pas graves qu'à
l'échelle médecin c'est pas grave pour
vaincre la peur plusieurs ateliers sont
organisés avec doudou même l'accès au
bloc opératoire se fait dans des
conditions presque réel organisé par
l'association au poème solidarité cette
matinée à l'hôpital des nounours a
également une portée pédagogique
apprendre à bien se brosser les dents ou
connaître par coeur les numéros
d'urgence les enfants apprennent en
s'amusant et en imaginant quand on leur
demande quelle doudou il ne trouve plein
de choses
il écoute le coeur du tout et souverain
c'est vraiment génial
et donc là ils sont vraiment à la geôle
imaginaire avec le plus fort et il vous
arrive à se concentrer suffisamment pour
que ça fonctionne et pour voir si le
tout a bien fonctionné les étudiants en
médecine passeront la semaine prochaine
en classe pour prendre des nouvelles des
doudous